bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les grandes
lignes de file echo le rugby un système
anti pluie pour vélo c'est ce que
propose un inventeur yvelinois il a créé
un système non quand qu'il permet
d'échapper aux gouttes de pluie nous
sommes allés le rencontrer sur son vélo
la tva appliquée à la filière équestre
passera de 7 à 20 % le 1er janvier
prochain
un tiers des centres équestres serait
menacé réactions des dirigeants de
centre et de leurs clients dans notre
dossier la semaine
et puis la fibre optique se développe
d'ici 2020 une centaine de communes des
yvelines devrait en bénéficier
elle est dix à vingt fois plus rapide
que l'actuelle adsl la ville de plaisir
à présenter les avancées de son chantier
à ses habitants et puis nous parlerons
de l'association dirigeants commerciaux
de france
la dcf ouvre à nouveau une antenne dans
les yvelines lancement se fera le 14
novembre
le président bruno me teulé pardon est
avec nous sur ce plateau mont soir on se
retrouve du coup dans un instant pour
parler un petit peu plus plus
profondément de cette association
avant cela je vous propose de découvrir
ce que parce qu'elle s'est passé cette
semaine au niveau économique
le siège français d'ikea à plaisir a été
perquisitionnée aujourd'hui les
policiers opèrent dans le cadre d'une
enquête sur les soupçons de surveillance
illicite de salariés et de clients la
sphère remonte à début 2012 et a déjà
donné lieu à une dizaine de mises en
examens la filière équestre se mobilise
elle refuse la hausse de la tva de 7 à
20 % en janvier prochain une opération
escargot était organisée ce matin entre
saint germes en les et rambouillet en
passant par versailles et plaisir était
à l'initiative du collectif lahore de 78
un collectif qui rassemble
professionnels amateurs éleveurs
cavaliers ou encore enseignants
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
réactions là le risque c'est que avec
une hausse de 13 points d'un coup on
puisse pas survivre si on ne répercute
pas sur les clients et d'un autre côté
si les clients c'est même pas sûr qu'ils
nous suivent
et on ne serait la seule coopération à
subir une hausse aussi importante de tva
donc puisque l'industrie du libre
notamment est toujours à 5-5 6 jeux si
je m'abuse
actuellement je suis dans une pension
auprès donc je paye 200 euros par cheval
et donc bah ça va faire une énorme
augmentation que pendant devant j'avoue
je n'ai pas calculé parce que ça fait
très peur une augmentation de tva pour
les pensent les jambes particulier comme
moi qui ont une pension c'est une chose
mais ça va clairement fermer des centres
équestres puisque le prix des cours va
augmenter quand on voudra prendre une
carte à l'année ça va faire un énorme
changement
le prix des pensions également vont
augmenter donc petit à petit ça va faire
fermer du monde ça va là je pense
honnêtement diriger de plus en plus de
gens vers des particuliers et du coup ça
va pas du tout servir la filière
professionnelle
d'autres mobilisations devrait suivre
notamment une manifestation les 18 et 19
novembre prochains dans toute la france
on soutient un cavalier partie des
bauges à cheval qui rejoindra paris nous
aurons l'occasion de faire un point
complet sur cette situation dans notre
dossier la semaine la pluie ne devrait
plus être un problème pour les cyclistes
un inventeur des essarts le roi a mis au
point un dispositif anti pluie une
invention originale que vous nous vous
proposons de découvrir en images un
sujet réalisé avec jonathan biemann sur
la selle de ce vélo arnaud sarfati ne
manque pas d'attirer les regards
cet inventeur nous présente ici son
dispositif anti pluie et anti froid
spécial cycliste habitués du deux roues
arnaud en avait assez d'être mouillés
après un an de recherche il pense avoir
trouvé la solution
un projet fou je pense que la phonie la
confiance un peu le propre des chefs
d'entreprise des créateurs c'est à dire
que oui ça fait peur mais
derrière chaque porte on voit d'autres
choses et tant qu'on n'a pas franchi la
première porte
quand on crée une entreprise on sait pas
ce qu'il ya derrière et donc l'idée
c'est il ya une part de folie et
d'inconscience j'en suis conscient mais
si on ne se lance pas
on sait jamais si ça peut aboutir cet
ingénieur n'en est pas à sa première
création il ya plus de dix ans il lance
un des sites leaders de covoiturage en
il vend cette société c'est aujourd'hui
le début d'une nouvelle aventure pour
arriver à mettre au point ce système
anti pluie arnaud a commencé par
réaliser différents prototypes
tout a commencé chez lui aux
essarts-le-roi donc là je suis dans mon
garage j'ai fait beaucoup de pièces avec
avec quelques outils donc un étau un
poste à soudure une paire de pinces et
puis du du fils de métal
en plus des structures métalliques il
fallait imaginer une tente une
couturière voile l'aïd et puis il a fait
appel à des industriels pour la
construction une quinzaine de prototypes
ont été réalisés avant d'arriver au
projet final
alors comment ça marche explications en
images
première étape la pose d armatures donc
le principe c'est que ça se montrent
très simplement sans je suis en faisant
ensuite on installe la toile à
différents modèles existent pour
s'adapter aux différents vélo existe en
vtt de ville et même pliable décrocher
permettent à la tente d'être tenues et
de baguettes maintiennent la structure
du dispositif un mètre cinquante de long
pour 1 mètre dix de hauteur un bon club
de prêt à porter pour se faire connaître
il se balade en ville protégée du rugby
et raconte ses aventures sur son blog ce
créateur propose dès aujourd'hui ces
différents modèles en quatre coloris
comptait 98 euros il a reçu une dizaine
de commandes et compte s'attaquer aux
pays nordiques
j'ai développé
deux pages une en allemand une en
anglais pour que le site internet
répondent aussi aux référencements dans
les différentes langues et qui soit
visible donc est accessible par ces
différents pays avec un investissement
de 100 mille euros
arnaud espèrent atteindre l'équilibré
d'ici deux à trois ans de plus en plus
de communes se dote de la fibre optique
elle offre un débit d'informations
nettement supérieur aux réseaux
existants pour l'internet mais aussi
pour la télévision ou encore la
visioconférence à plaisir le chantier a
démarré en 2012
un reportage de catherine mulato et
jonathan vilma la fibre optique on en
parle beaucoup mais peu l'utilisent
encore pour cause sur le département son
déploiement a été lancé en 2010 par
orange et sfr pour couvrir d'ici 2020
une centaine de communes ce qui
représente pour vous donner quelques
repères
83 % des logements qui seront donc
déployés par l'initiative privée dans le
département la fibre optique a été
déployé sur le secteur de saint germain
en laye les boucles de seine plaisir
fait partie des 20 premières communes
fibres et 50 % des logements peuvent
potentiellement y accéder trois critères
on va dire il ya un critère de densité
un critère technique
on sent des équipements des centraux
téléphoniques et puis on va en priorité
dans des communes dans des quartiers de
communes où le réseau adsl apporte un
déni le plus faible
enfin le plus faible
le déploiement de la fibre sur la ville
de plaisir devrait s'achever d'ici 2015
l'ensemble des habitants et des
entreprises pourront profiter d'un
réseau 10 à 20 fois plus rapide que
l'adsl
de quoi intéresser ceux qui veulent
utiliser de nouveaux services comme la
télé en 3d télécharger ou envoyer des
fichiers très lourd un défi stratégique
pour les communes qui espère ainsi
attirer des entreprises à forte demande
technologique économique pour les
opérateurs qui investissent de lourdes
sommes 2 milliards d'euros rien que pour
orange pour l'ensemble du territoire
une opération de reboisement un peu
particulière s'est déroulée ce mardi à
thoiry à l'initiative du projet une
agence de recrutement
l'opération un boulot poids en bouleau
signifie un arbre pour au moins un
emploi je vous proposais d' écouter le
directeur de l' agence on a décidé de
mettre en place
version un boulot pour un boulot c'est à
dire qu'à chaque finale en personne
accompagné que ce soit en cas de
recrutement ou en accompagnement
personnalisé on va planter un arbre
l'année d'après voilà est donc
aujourd'hui on en plante 164 à thoiry
c'est notre quatrième opération est ce
qui est important pour nous c'est que
notre entreprise participe à son échelle
a effectivement le développement durable
est donc planté des arbres énormément de
symbolique à la fois dans le domaine de
l'environnement puisque on plante un
arbre il va pousser va grandir il va
devenir une source de richesse aussi
industriels pour des gens comme le
groupe deya mais c'est également vrai
quand on plante quelqu'un dans une
entreprise c'est pour qu'ils grandissent
c'est pour qu'ils apportent de la valeur
voilà donc la symbolique pour nous est
extrêmement liés et pour le parc de
thoiry cette initiative lui a permis de
planter des essences rares dans son parc
comme des bouleaux et des pains de chine
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
d'île de france et google ont signé hier
un partenariat autour du projet google
pour les pros il s'agit pour les tpe pme
artisans et commerçants d'ile-de-france
de mieux tirer profit d'internet car les
pme les plus actives en ligne
exporterait et se développerait deux
fois plus que la moyenne une trentaine
de coach google vont donc aider les
entrepreneurs à développer leurs
activités en ligne
l'initiative existe déjà
d'autres régions autre qu un autre
information concernant la cci ile de
france la chambre a mené en septembre
une enquête auprès de dirigeants
d'entreprises dans 407 dans les yvelines
les résultats dans le département ne
sont pas forcément réjouissant comme
vous pouvez le voir sur cette
infographie
près de la moitié des entreprises ont
subi une régression du chiffre
d'affaires au début de l'année
les secteurs les plus touchés le
commerce notamment les détaillants non
alimentaire il est maintenant temps de
passer à l'entretien
la semaine prochaine à l'association des
dirigeants commerciaux de france des
yvelines fait son lancement son
président bruno mutelet était sur notre
plateau bonsoir
alors va nous recevoir de rien du tout
d'abord pouvez-vous nous donner quelques
quelques explications qu est-ce que
c'est vraiment cette association
alors c'est une association qui est basé
essentiellement sur la création de
réseaux ans il faut pas se leurrer on va
pas ce qui est là voyez la face c'est
comme ça que ça marche mais on par le
biais du développement de on va dire de
l'action la performance commerciale au
sein des entreprises donc on va par ce
biais là par le biais de conférences
qu'on va donner sur des sujets
d'actualité ou des sujets opportun qui
serait important de parler à ce moment
là on va faire des conférences sur ces
sujets et ça va permettre de rassembler
des gens des chefs d'entreprises bien
entendu puisque c'est notre cible par
les échanges et après et puis essayer de
dégager des synergies
c'est l'objectif c'est une association
qui est assez ancien oui tout à fait a
été créée en 1930 on voyait ça ça d'être
un petit peu et donc ça c'est la
fédération anfp est qui et qui chapeaute
au niveau national et puis en dessous en
région ile de france notamment et puis
les départements qui sont les
associations au niveau des départements
sont des associations citées plus haut
donc le réseau d'associations
effectivement est ancien dans les
yvelines
l'association dcf 78 existait déjà été
fermée quelques années elle renaît on
admire aujourd'hui voilà elle était
fermée en 2005 et elle renaît
aujourd'hui effectivement ce qu'on était
attaché entre guillemets au dcf 95 et
donc vous voyez le 95 78 une grosse
région
donc il était opportun je pense de
scinder les deux entités et de repartir
sur des bonnes bases en 78 avec toutes
les entreprises qui sont jouées en 78
tours essayer de créer plein de
synergies pourquoi avoir pris la
présidence
et est-ce que c'est parti d'une élection
d'un alors objectivement bon parce que
c'est vrai qu'il faut quand même trouver
des gens on est bénévole donc
il n'a pas énormément de gens qui se
bousculent au portillon donc c'est une
opportunité que j'ai eus puisque ma
voisine est présidente du dcf 95
aujourd'hui jusqu'à aujourd'hui elle va
passer le pouvoir dans les jours qui
viennent et prendre la tête des dcf
ile-de-france donc au niveau régional
donc là ça sera important aussi pour
nous d'avoir cette panique aubert qui
sera qui est très connu dans les essais
f
et aussi dans les yvelines puisqu'elle a
fait beaucoup de choses pour en parler
parce que c'est vrai qu'à beaucoup de
choses à dire sur un nid caubère bonne
chose et donc laisser sera longue et
voilà exactement d'une autre entrevue
et donc c'est au détour d'une
conversation avec elle que j'avais dit
ben tiens si tu as besoin d'un coup de
main pour développer le 78 je serai ton
et elle a repris la balle au bond et
quelques mois plus tard il m'a dit bah
allons-y on va se lancer dans l'aventuré
alors vous parliez de conférences de
réunions de travail
finalement concrètement dans les
yvelines qu'est ce qui va être mis en
place alors concrètement dans les
yvelines y aura des statutaires tous les
tous les mois qui vont tourner autour
d'un sujet particulier
la première va s'organiser chez jean
claude decaux à plaisir donc on je
remercie très très très fort jean claude
decaux qui nous a permis d'organiser
cette première chez eux sur un site
historique bon qu'un de renommer un jean
claude decaux internationale et par la
suite bien sûr il y aura des statutaires
qui vont se faire tous les mois à peu
près parce qu'on
quand il y aura les congés tout ça on
pourra pas nécessairement organisé mais
l'idée c'est d'en faire tous les mois
sur un sujet particulier et pour
rassembler un maximum de personnes mais
sans dépasser non plus les cinquante
personnes parce qu'après ça devient plus
impersonnel et on veut garder cet aspect
vraiment de communication que les gens
rentrent en contact et qu'on plus
connaît soit finalement ces principes ou
vous allez aussi mettre en place la
semaine nationale de performance
commerciale donc il y aura élevé dans
deux ans on a un différend
donc c'est de ce fait qui ment c'est un
c'est une désorganisation que nous
faisons qui est organisé tous les deux
ans donc là elle et il part sur
plusieurs critères donc on va
sélectionner certaines entreprises qui
au niveau de leur performance ce soit au
niveau du résultat ou de chiffre
d'affaires qui ont vraiment une grosse
progression sur une année à l'autre ou
sur une période déterminée
ça va être l'origine faire l'objet d'un
trophée ensuite via l'innovation
on a vu durant le reportage tout à
l'heure la personne avec la protection
de son vélo ça peut être quelqu'un qui
peut être éligible à un trophée puisque
c'est une belle innovation qui l'a fait
qu'il a fait ici est bon bah pourquoi
pas je veux faire participer à nos
trophées puisque c'est l'objectif il ya
également un trophée à l'international
dont l'entreprise qui exporte ou qui a
trouvé un secteur où une niche exportés
mais qui marche très bien à
l'exportation ça sera un objet également
deux trophées et pour finir enfin par
la performance globale donc c'est des
sélections qui commence dans le
département et qui finissent qui
commence dans le département qui bromont
aux régionales des élections à chaque
fois et qui combine au dessert
malheureusement cette année il ya
personne des yvelines mais je suis sûr
que dans deux ans il y aura quelqu'un
désigné alors au jour où vous travaillez
donc avec des entreprises mais également
avec des jeunes qui n'ont pas encore ne
sont pas encore entrés dans son marché
du travail a exactement là ce sera le
concours national de la
commercialisation
exactement je crois vous avez déjà
rencontré des écoles du département à ce
sujet voilà donc on a eu un lauréat
de l'école sup devait qui a été jusqu'en
demi finale donc jusqu'au niveau
régional c'est déjà très bien puisque
pour lui ça sera une belle opportunité
une belle une belle carte de visite
puisque sur un cv ça valorise d'avoir
participé à un concours comme celui là
cette année en plus c'était à des coûts
qui était le partenaire et ça s'est très
bien passé puisque sur un sujet bien
déterminé les étudiants ont pu
s'exprimer montré de hrinova le créa
s'ils vont créativité qu'est ce qu'il va
faire en lordan alors on leur donnait un
sujet et puis après ils doivent le
développer montrer comment comment ils
l'interprètent et et puis après c'est
évalué par un jury et puis en fonction
du résultat fonction du travail effectué
et on va dire bon bah c'est bien et puis
après une élection comme toujours
alors au sein d'edf vous avez également
créé un orgue un observatoire permanent
de la fonction commerciale
le but c'est donc d'étudier le secteur
oui vous avez également des magazines
alors magazine propre à dcf mais
également pour le grand public voilà
tout à fait donc tribu c'est le magazine
qui est propre et des rangs pendant
lequel on retrouve bien sûr des articles
qu'on fait avec bien sûr des gens des
partenaires mais également des gens en
interne et puis le magazine action
commerciale qui est musulman écran très
bien et qui lui est originaire fins et
les dcf qui ont qui sont à l'origine de
ce magazine
mais maintenant il est repris évidemment
dans les kiosques et on a toujours de
trois pages sur sur les dcf pour faire
référence à l'origine alors dans le
parlons excusez moi précédemment on a vu
un petit bout de l'enquêté médiamétrie
oui on avait une fille voilà où
justement on observer que les
entreprises commerciales n'étaient pas
dans leur meilleure forme ces temps-ci
59 % des entreprises interrogées ont
connu une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
dans les six derniers mois
est ce que c'est quelque chose justement
qui ce qui se ressent alors moi
personnellement j'ai pas eu de retour
par rapport à ça mais aujourd'hui vu mon
le métier que j'exerce oui alors je peux
il ya effectivement des entreprises
aujourd'hui qui sont en difficultés de
trésorerie
certaines arrivent à tirer leur épingle
du jeu mais c'est toujours à la force du
poignet j'ai envie de dire que on a qu
elle arrive celles qui sont en tout cas
en bonne condition qu'elles arrivent à
s'en sortir
donc ce sera l'objet également de du de
la semaine de l'inauguration sera sur
optimisme et dépassement de soi je crois
que c'est un bon sujet justement pour
aider les chefs d'entreprise aujourd'hui
à se dépasser pour arriver à sortir leur
épingle du jeu dans une situation
économique n'est pas favorable pour
l'instant mais l'optimisme revient je le
sens dans l'exemple du coup il ya est ce
qu'il ya des actions peut-être qu'il qui
peuvent être mises en place pour aider
les entreprises de ce secteur sont mal
en point oui bien entendu
alors par le biais justement de nos
conférences qu'on organise sur tel ou
tel sujet elles peuvent effectivement en
profiter directement si un sujet qui les
intéresse en particulier il venir bien
entendu ils participaient ou carrément
être à l'origine du de la conférence on
a parlé par exemple récemment dans 95 du
cic le crédit impôt compétitivité emploi
qui est assez mal compris par les chefs
d'entreprise et qui peut être
effectivement une
voilà une solution est d'un apport de
trésorerie quelque part très bien merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur votre plateau
merci à vous et on vous souhaite une
bonne soirée d'inauguration
merci beaucoup on passe maintenant au
dossier la semaine
l'équitation en péril c'est en tout cas
le discours que tiennent à les
professionnels du secteur
depuis que le gouvernement a voté une
hausse de la tva
elle passe à 20 % au 1er janvier un coup
dur pour cette troisième fédération
sportive de france
yolaine thorez jonathan willeman et
patrick jacques de dixmude sont allés
dans différents centres équestres du
département pour faire un point sur la
situation au centre équestre de magny
les hameaux c'est le rituel du mercredi
les cavaliers préparent leur cheval
avant le cours collectifs pour la
plupart beaucoup plus qu'un sport
l'équitation est une véritable passion
une passion qui risque de devenir plus
cher l'année prochaine sous l'injonction
de la commission européenne à la france
est dans l'obligation d'appliquer un
taux plein de tva sur l'ensemble des
activités équestres
autrement dit on passerait de 7 à 20 %
de tva dès le 1er janvier 2014
résultat les clubs seraient amenés à
augmenter leurs tarifs
au risque de faire une croix sur une
partie de la clientèle certains parents
payent aujourd'hui entre 500 et 700
euros par an pour l'activité de leurs
enfants
j'essaierai si je peux la satisfaire
tout le temps mais
arrivé à un moment le budget c'est quand
même assez difficile
déjà que c'est pas donné c'est un sport
qu'elle aime assez cher donc je trouve
ça honteux quoi ça dommage si une hausse
de la tva
je me les tarifs vont augmenter et je ne
sais pas si je pourrai souvenirs
au besoin de continuer le poney pour
elle et moi mon kart tension moins de
clients c'est aussi moins d'argent pour
rémunérer les employés des centres
équestres catherine gère le haras de gaz
rend depuis 26 ans sur les cinq salariés
qu'elle emploie elle envisage peut-être
de supprimer un poste à cause de la
future taxe
moi je vais perdre des clients voilà qui
pourront pas suivre
voilà et puis bah après devoir licencier
parce que si on a moins de chiffre
d'affaires moins de rentrées on pourra
pas garder tout le personnel le ghn dont
je fais partie estimé qu'ils auraient à
peu près 6000 postes en france qui vont
être supprimés à cause de cette
augmentation de tva les petites
structures qui était déjà affaibli un
petit peu avec la crise risquent pas
s'en remettre
ah oui ça c'est certain les centres
équestres ont déjà connu des remous
concernant leur tva mais celles
annoncées pour l'année prochaine est de
loin la plus menaçante pour selon la
fédération nationale du cheval 2000
entreprises seraient en péril
en 2004 la filière équestre bénéficier
d'une tva réduite à 5,5 pour cent
à l'époque l'objectif était de
promouvoir l'équitation
il y a deux ans elle était passée à 7%
l'année dernière une activité était déjà
passé à 19 6% celle du commerce des
chevaux sports et loisirs là aussi sous
la pression l'union européenne à noter
que le commerce des chevaux d'élevage et
de consommation lui reste taxé à hauteur
de 7% l'année prochaine ce seront toutes
les activités du centre équestre qui
passeront à 19,6 pour sans me lasser
d'une saisine de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne pour manquement sur
manquements et d'une amende de plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros
le gouvernement veut se mettre en
conformité rapidement un coup dur pour
le département des yvelines avec et 21
mille licenciés et plus de 200 centres
il est le deuxième département équestre
de france derrière le nord à rambouillet
deborah ne craint pas la fermeture de
son entreprise qu'elle estime viable
pour autant elle ne comprend pas cette
hausse de la tva dans l'équitation
contrairement aux autres sports les
subventions sont quasi inexistantes
ce sont surtout des établissements
professionnels du coup il est parfois
difficile pour les gérants de se faire
une marge réelle les frais de
fonctionnement sont très lourds
les structures coûte cher le les chevaux
demande beaucoup d'entretien il mange il
demande à ce qu'on s'occupe d'eux pas
cinq jours sur sept et pas 35 heures
comme une entreprise qui ferme ses
portes ou un gymnase
donc voila nous c'est sept jours sur
sept il sont malades ces 24 heures sur
et bah tout ça ça se paye quoi ça un
coup si l'équitation s'est démocratisé
ces dernières années elle reste encore
assez coûteuse
à 26 ans thomas a déjà 16 ans de
pratique derrière lui et prépare son
diplôme pour être enseignant cavaliers
depuis un an il est aussi propriétaire
de zaz y ait un cheval qui lui coûte
plus de 400 euros par mois pour la
pension et dont il pense déjà à se
séparer
faute de pouvoir assumer cette future
hausse des prix on commence à penser à
arrêter les concours on commence à
penser à arrêter d'acheter nouveaux
équipements à son cheval est on comment
ça c'est pas qu'on perd du plaisir mais
effectivement à ça devient un peu dur de
2 pensez vraiment que ce soit juste un
loisir
et pas une contrainte selon les
professionnels de la filière si deux
chevaux se retrouve sans propriétaire
ils seront contraints de quitter des
écuries et pourrait prendre la direction
des abattoirs bon bah on se débarrasse
des shows quoi c'est à dire que en
général c'est triste à dire mais bon
voilà que les chevaux qui ne servent pas
ils partent pour l'alimentation
d'après le groupement épique nationale
sur les deux cent cinquante mille
chevaux que contre les centres
d'équitation 80000 seraient envoyés à
l'abattoir pour se faire entendre les
professionnels se mobilisent dans le
département ils ont organisé une
opération escargot ce jeudi et leur
groupe facebook créé il ya quelques
jours compte déjà plus de 700 abonnés
est le ministère des sports et le
ministère de l'agriculture dont ils
dépendent seraient sensibles à leur
action mais les professionnels du
secteur attendent toujours une réponse
concrète la hausse de la tva reste donc
pour l'instant maintenu
maintenant le temps de passer à l'agenda
une date à retenir jeudi prochain la
cgpme yvelines organise un petit
déjeuner d'information sur la banque
publique d'investissement et ses
dispositifs de financement seront
également évoqués le crédit d'impôt
compte it compétitivité pardon et la
plateforme de financement initiative
saint quentin en yvelines
attention il faut s'inscrire toutes les
informations s'affichent sur votre écran
sera de 8h30 à 11h à la ferme du manet à
montigny le bretonneux
c'est la fin de ce fil est qu merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine et d'ici là
bonne soirée
faux